Oh
[Music]
I'm honest a minute I am so excited to
introduce you to my guest
Margaret James it's James James berry
because I am a man Margaret is a woman's
name and I am most definitely
undoubtedly a man sure I've got rippling
muscles and a huge penis look at the way
I sit ya see that it's nice huh anyway
dr. James Barry is one of the very first
female doctor I am a man okay
James Margaret Barry is born to a super
progressive family so progressive that
they give her the name of her dead uncle
and then send her off to medical school
they passed me off as a teenage boy it
was very easy are you sure he's actually
a boy seems very feminine he is wearing
pants he's a man I head off to the
Crimean War where I prove myself to be a
most talented doctor next James performs
the first-ever c-section we're both the
mother and child lip and I'm one of the
first doctors to practice good hygiene
who knew on your hand and
putting it near an open wound was bad oh
yeah I did welcome
for over 40 years nobody knew that James
lived privately as a woman living with
his secret like this maybe Eames prone
to outbursts and he was known to have a
very very short fuse no I don't that's a
lie
oh that's better
dr. James berry a lesson in courage and
perseverance did I ever tell you about
that time someone made fun of my voice
let me guess
I'm at the sharp end of your tongue I
bloody shot them James no oh relax I
didn't use that gun I use this one oh my
god
[Music]